after watching episode 2 of Netflix's
latest season of Black Mirror I can
definitely say I'll never be doing a
documentary about my parents Locke Henry
is a chilling tale about the horrors of
discovering your parents sex life so
naturally we'll be taking a deep dive
into its ending and all the fun Black
Mirror Easter eggs throughout and trust
me there are a lot so make sure to tape
the latest episode of Bergerac we're
going to solve a murder meet Davis
McArdle a young documentarian making his
way through the Rolling Hills of
Scotland he's with his girlfriend Pia to
make a riveting documentary on a guy who
protects endangered eggs which we'll
actually see referenced in a newspaper
article near the end of the episode but
as he and Pia explore the sights and
sounds of Locke Henry a far more
riveting story calls to them one which
has a personal connection to Davis
himself along the way Davis stops at his
mother Janet's it's been some time since
he's been back home having attended
London for film school and we get to
experience Janet's home through Piazza
eyes both we the viewer and her taken
all the weird knickknacks including
multiple VHS tapes of Bergerac a British
detective series that aired for 10 years
and this creepy mask keep your eye on
both of these things as they'll come
into play later on the house is pretty
quiet with Davis's Father Kenneth having
died when he was only eight years old
there's also a bit of foreshadowing with
Pia checking out a novel called River of
death for those of you who know the
ending it's a pretty fun detail now the
story doesn't really get going until
Davis meets up with childhood friend and
Pub owner Stuart who you may remember
played Podrick in Game of Thrones he is
curious why this beautiful Town isn't
inundated with tourists and thus were
introduced to the tale of Ian Adair back
in 1997 kennett's father a policeman was
tasked with checking on Ian after he
threatened the local pub owner but when
he got there he was shot Ian went on to
kill himself and his mother and father
with police uncover covering a creepy
sex slash torture dungeon on his
property in total eight murders were
attributed to Ian including a couple on
their honeymoon pay attention to This
Woman's butterfly pin we'll be sure to
see that later on unfortunately Kenneth
contracted MRSA a bacterial infection
while recovering in the hospital and
that eventually killed him over time so
both Davis and Janet count Kenneth's
death as Ian's doing although it's a
touchy subject Pia believes Davis
personal angle and the fact that an egg
documentary sucks eggs could make for an
amazing documentary and thus they team
up with Stuart to pitch the documentary
to fake production company historic you
know it's cool because it's spelled with
a K by highlighting the story they could
bring tourists back to lock Henry and
commemorate those who died in the slangs
and as we're treated to a montage of the
team collecting documents footage and
other material there are a bunch of fun
Easter eggs this paper has an article on
MP Michael smart being in hot water he's
from episode 5 this season and a
documentary about him can be seen in
Joan is awful in fact many of the
Articles throughout the episode mention
smart like this one where he says he'll
launch a new party one where he vows to
return and this one where his comments
about visitors overstaying their welcome
is rebuked but my favorite takes place
in this ticker where we can read
Michael's smart unveils met police robot
dog a nod to season for his Metal Head
about a killer robotic dog who
coincidentally stalks the Scottish
Countryside there's also a toy robot dog
in Davis's bedroom the back of Davis's
laptop is also filled with fun Easter
eggs like the Tucker soft logo the
company that made bandersnatch the white
bear logo the Archangel logo and the
Waldo mascot from season two's the Waldo
moment again there's another ticker
later on that reads politician Waldo
romps to victory in Italy if you
remember Waldo was a cartoon figure that
ran for office so Davis and Pia get the
go-ahead from historic to shoot the
documentary in the background you can
see they produce the calow years a
documentary about the British PM Michael
callow who had to have sex with a pig
this dog can also be seen on stringberry
in episode 1's Joan is awful the gang
breaks into the underground Sex Dungeon
for some exclusive footage even using a
black light to see the blood and other
bodily fluids still strewn about the
room but it's when they're on their way
back home that they crash into a tractor
putting Davis in the hospital luckily
Stewart and Pia get off relatively
unscathed but Davis will need to stay
the night prompting Pia to stay at
Janet's this is where things really take
a turn while uploading their old VHS
footage Pia finds that the old Bergerac
tapes they were using contain actual
footage of Davis's Mom and Dad
committing the lock Henry murders that
honeymoon couple that went missing was
captured and tortured in the underground
bunker where Ian Adair would film as
Janet comes out in a nurse outfit and
mask this same mask found in the living
room at the same time at Davis's visit
visited by Stewart's Father Richard who
for decades suspected Kenneth and Janet
were the killers as we'll find out in
the lock Henry documentary trailer shown
at the end of the episode Richard would
engage in sex acts with the couple and
their behavior made him think that maybe
Ian didn't act alone in the murders the
thing is Richard never had any proof and
perhaps this is what led him to his
drinking holding that secret for so many
years soon the real story unravels
Kenneth killed Ian and his family Ian
was becoming a liability getting drunk
at the bar and shooting his mouth off so
Kenneth shot himself to make it look
like it was all Ian's doing and with
this discovery Pia runs into the
bathroom and checks her phone where we
get another Easter egg one of her
contacts is Yorkie the name of the main
character in San Junipero set up earlier
in the episode is the fact that Janet's
home has no cell service so Pia makes
her Escape but is chased down by Janet
who put the pieces together that Pia had
figured out her murderous past Pia
eventually makes a run for the river
where she trips and bashes her head on a
rock her death was actually foreshadowed
by Davis near the beginning of the
episode when he talks about the dangers
of the countryside
you say completely dangerous
there's deep water and all that you know
we also have that fun River of death
book now Janet doesn't know that pia has
died and perhaps there's a world where
if Janet were to deny everything she
could have gotten out of this mess
instead she believes she's soon to be
arrested and hangs herself but that's
not before we get to see she's kept a
box full of her victim's mementos among
them is the butterfly pin the same pin
we saw on the honeymoon couple Janet
leaves out this box and multiple VHS
tapes for Davis to collect writing him a
note that reads for your film nothing
like leaving your child a bunch of snuff
films you made it's pretty ironic that
Davis set out to do a documentary about
the lock Henry murders then becomes the
subject of it himself I thought it was
really cool that we got to see a fake
trailer for this lock Henry show and it
got me really disappointed because I
actually wanted to watch it mixed into
the trailer are several other Easter
eggs including the ticker us tourist
found dead at Saito Gamu a reference to
season three's play test situ gemu was
also the developer of season 5's
fighting games striking vipers there's
also a reference to Hotshot editions
opening in Sydney the talent show found
in season 1's 15 million merits I think
one of the funniest articles though is
that a former PM Michael Kalo the one
who had relations with the pig while
he's now running a zoo which is really
interesting since in season Four's
nosedive he's seen posting just got
thrown out of the zoo again fast forward
again and lock Henry is a huge success
even nominated for best documentary at
the baftas but if you listen closely
you'll recognize the two other docs it's
running against are from the Black
Mirror world first is suffer the
children about the tiply pedo ring from
demon 79 and the second euthanasia
inside project Judah pero about season
3's San Junipero Locke Henry wins the
award and Davis finds some
congratulatory champagne from
streamberry in his hotel room Stuart
even gives him a call stating that the
place has been booked up for weeks with
tourists Davis got what he wanted to be
a recognized documentarian but the quest
question remains at what cost then
there's the note Janet left she wanted
him to have her mementos and tapes for
this movie deep down I think this is
some Macabre Act of love to give her son
the most horrific elements of herself so
that he could become successful you
could also argue this is more
egotistical with her wanting to gain
Renown but I think if that were the case
she wouldn't have killed herself now I
turn it over to you what did you think
of lock Henry and how has it compared to
the other episodes this season let me
know in the comments below thanks for
watching please be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember we
had such fun together
foreign